vous êtes déjà posé la question est-ce
que je suis un bon acteur oh oui et je
ne suis pas modeste je me suis posé la
question et souvent j'y réponds
immédiatement oui
je vous assure j'ai pas de modestie et
donc je dis je suis un bon acteur je
suis sûr de toute façon je ne
il faut pas douter à un moment parce que
si en revanche c'est pas parce que je
suis bonne acteur que j'ai pas la
trouille donc je vous donne un exemple
simple et après je vous laisse
tranquille
je venais de tourner avec Edouard
Édouard Bert et ah c'était sauvage en 15
jours on a fait un film et j'étais libre
je me trouvais impeccable quoi je te
jure je suis arrivé juste après
j'enchaînais avec le film de Clovis
Cornillac où je fais un banquier
un peu retard
j'y vais
sur devoir j'avais déjà pas j'avais déjà
c'est pendant le covid
costume magnifique allez c'est parti
première séquence première journée c'est
un colis gourmet est-ce que tu crois pas
que je patauge dans la choucroute mais
tu peux même pas imaginer
j'étais sûr de moi je t'assure je
m'assois dans le fauteuil
je commence à paniquer j'ai paniqué
mon texte n'est plus
vas-y que je te déballe des trucs
ce jour-là j'ai appelé ma femme et j'ai
dit je veux rembourser l'argent je veux
rentrer je n'y arriverai jamais Clovis
va me calme-toi calme-toi j'étais
persuadé que qu'on avait jeté en sort
donc ça m'empêche pas d'avoir peur donc
je trouve être un bon acteur mais il y a
des jours où j'étais vraiment mauvais et
ce jour-là je sais pas ce qui m'a mon
bouton a même pété pendant le jeu je
vais j'ai perdu mes moyens je sais pas
ce qui m'est arrivé je vais
je bloqué dedans et Dieu merci Clovis a
beaucoup d'élégance il m'a dit
donc tu vois il faut être sûr de soi
mais tu as toujours un accident qui peut
arriver
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé à la province donc
chinois à la province si tu veux je
travaille pour ma région donc ça c'est
mon premier job quand je suis sorti de
l'école et sinon avant j'ai vendu des
frites
vous en avez moins en France des
baraques à frites mais
chez nous il y en a beaucoup et Dieu
sait si jamais mais en faire cette
hommage à ceux qui le font c'est un
boulot et pouvoir table et pourtantable
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
affreux je le souhaite à personne
parce qu'il fallait les peler parce
qu'il faut faire on a fait beaucoup de
plusieurs cuisson tu vois et maintenant
quand je mange des frites toujours j'ai
une sorte de
oui respect
[Musique]
on écrivait des scénarios ensemble on
dessinait ensemble et lui quand on avait
fini ce que vous vous appelez votre bac
nous humanités on dit en Belgique et lui
il est parti dans une école de cinéma et
moi j'ai continué de le dessin et en
fait il avait besoin d'un mec qui n'ait
pas peur de la caméra pour faire ses
exercices d'école et donc j'ai fait ces
exercices d'école c'est des films d'une
minute deux minutes trois minutes et
puis après on a fait un court-métrage
ensemble pour s'amuser et puis en
prenant c'est arrivé près de chez vous
[Musique]
j'adore les gens qui disent n'importe
quoi ça me ressemble assez qui fait
n'importe quoi et
je garde un souvenir des gens de ces
deux saisons on s'amusait comme des
péter à faire ça parce que tu peux dire
ce que tu veux comme tu veux je suis
1000 je sais pas combien de personnages
je fais dans Monsieur Manhattan je
cherche je suis tout quoi je fais des
partout j'ai tout fait dans Manhattan
j'ai tout inventé j'ai tout fait je suis
écrivain je suis tout ce que je veux
[Musique]
il fallait que je danse en chantant
de trois fois par semaine et tout ça à
Paris et en fait on s'est rendu compte
que je l'avais jamais la tête donc un
moment quand on s'approchait du tournage
il dit il faut solutionner le problème
parce que et en fait on s'est rendu
compte
que c'est parce qu'il y avait des
miroirs dans les dans les salles de
danse et que je n'avais pas regardé et
en fait ils m'ont trouvé une salle de
danse avec les Bernadette
de danse où il y avait pas de miroir et
à partir de là j'ai pu relever la tête
donc mon pire souvenir de préparation
puisque après je n'ai plus jamais rien
préparé c'est la danse
[Musique]
je l'ai fait parce que j'adore les bois
les livres lus donc avant j'écoutais
énormément de livres lui même si je lis
mais j'adore écouter la voix comment on
porte la voix comment la voie trade
elle porte beaucoup de choses il y a
beaucoup de encore une fois je trouve
que l'image est souvent en dessous de ce
que peut faire le son la voix et tout ça
j'aime mieux la comédie que le drame je
trouve ça plus difficile à faire de
faire rire que de faire pleurer mais
j'aime bien tout moi j'ai la physique
pas terrible donc moi c'est une chance
c'est plus facile quand un physique
comme le mien parce que tu peux passer
de tout à tout si tu es trop jolie ou
trop jolie en attendant à penser que tu
seras pas capable de faire rire alors
que je connais des tas d'actrices très
très jolie à qui on ne propose jamais de
comédie ou d'être méchante ou d'être tu
vois de monter dans les tours quoi
moi j'ai cette chance là donc pour moi
[Musique]
me gêne moi à la longue c'est
j'ai du mal à parler de moi alors quand
on a l'impression que je parle tout le
temps de moi alors que je dis ça c'est
pas du tout dans ma nature je suis très
extraverti c'est un fait c'est pas parce
que je parle fort que je veux qu'on
m'entendre mais l'action de parler de ce
que je fais m'a toujours mis en
truc donc ce côté là il y a plein de
fois où j'ai envie de dire ça ça me fait
chier est-ce que c'est possible juste de
faire le film et après vous me laissez
tranquille si j'ai bien fait mon boulot
faut que le réalisateur me dise ok c'est
ce que j'attendais et puis voilà j'ai
fini c'est un peu comme un peintre
bâtiment quoi vous êtes content j'ai mis
deux couches je pense pas quand même 23
pour moi c'est parfait voilà j'habite
pas là et je n'ai pas besoin d'expliquer
pendant trois ans alors je suis parti
sur un blanc et un petit camaïeu qui va
je m'en fous